hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show so for those of you who follow my
channel
you'll know that i'm interested in any
study relating to the microbiome
so i was pretty interested when the
study came out just the other day
from nature the maternal microbiome
modulates fetal neurodevelopment in mice
so i thought it'd be cool to talk about
this paper in more detail
and highlight some of the key features
that examine
the connection between the mothers so
the maternal microbiome
and brain development in mouse fetuses
so yep as i've just said this is a mild
study not a human study
but this is nonetheless still very
interesting and furthers my prediction
that we will see a lot more insight into
the microbiome in the coming years
as techniques and tools to study it
enhance so
in this video i'll first just give a
brief background then we'll talk about
the study
and their results and maybe talk a bit
more about how this might be happening
and what is the link between maternal
microbiome and
neuronal development in offspring and
then lastly i'll give a bit of an
outlook
so the microbiome is a fancy word used
to describe the different bacteria
viruses and fungi within our bodies
so effectively everything that isn't
human cells and
majority of the time the microbiome is
referring to bacteria
in particular bacteria that inhabits the
gut microbiome so this is bacteria
present within your large intestine
and so this gut microbiome is not just a
passenger within our bodies
it plays an active role through the
secretion of a variety of different
compounds that they generate
that can influence metabolism immunity
and of relevance for this video
neuronal development and previous
studies reinforced this point
in particular studies in mice have shown
that the maternal gut microbiator
is necessary for maintaining normal
fetal development
after maternal inflammation and that
changes in the maternal microbiota
due to having consumption of a high fat
diet
can also lead to neurobehavioral
abnormalities
in the offspring however it isn't
necessarily clear from these studies
whether or not these alterations in the
maternal microbiota
is affecting development of the fetus
during gestation
or postnatally moreover it was currently
unclear
whether or not the maternal microbiota
can influence the developing embryo
in unstressful conditions so in normal
homeostasis
so that's what the authors of this paper
set out to achieve
so to understand the results of this
paper you need to understand the three
different conditions the authors had the
mice growing in
firstly you've got your control mice
secondly
they had germ-free mice which are mice
that are reared the void of
microbial colonization and then lastly
they had antibiotic treated mice
that due to the nature of antibiotics
depletes the microbiome
so these were the conditions used for
the pregnant mice
and then the authors examined the
phenotypes and neurophysiology
of the embryos and so the first main
finding
that the study showed was that the
maternal microbiota
promotes axonogenesis so genesis
referring to generation
and axon referring to the axon of a
neuron which is the lung process
of the neuron so the studies show that
in mid-gestation stage
embryos of microbiota deficient mothers
so the germ-free
mothers or the antibiotic treated
mothers
had neuronal projections so the axons
connecting the region of the cortex to
the thalamus just two different brain
regions
were smaller and shorter than the
control mother offspring
and so the thalamus is a small structure
within the brain
and its main function is to relay motor
and sensory signals to the cerebral
cortex
and so maybe it wasn't surprising that
the authors found that the offspring
from
microbiota deficient mothers had
impairments
in neurobehavioral responses to foreport
and hind poor tactile stimuli
however they didn't see any differences
in their visual sensory behavior
or their motor coordination and so
whilst this might be interesting the key
question
is why and how was the depletion of the
microbiota
influencing the fetal development of the
brain
and so since the gut microbiota produces
a variety of different
biochemicals into the circulating blood
of the mother
that is why the authors decided to look
and interestingly
by looking at the metabolites produced
from the mother
on these different conditions to whether
or not they were germ-free treated with
antibiotics or the
control mice they saw that there was a
clear difference
in the metabolomic profile so what this
means is that
in the maternal serum there were some
metabolites that were higher
within the control mice than in the
microbiota depleted mice and the authors
found that by taking
four of the metabolites that are much
higher in the control mothers
could actually rescue and promote the
axonogenesis within the offspring of the
microbiota depleted
mothers and this also helped to improve
the tactile sensory behavior of the mice
so to quote from the actual article the
overall take-home is that
the results show that the maternal
microbiome promotes
fetal phthalamocortical actinogenesis
and mice
properly via microbiota dependent
biochemicals
such as tmao and ip in the fetal brain
so this study supports previous research
showing a connection between the gut
microbiome
and fetal development particularly of
the brain
but it still isn't entirely clear why
offspring from microbiota depleted
mothers
show specific defects in reactions to
heat sound
and pressure detection but the study
nonetheless
further raises a warning for the use of
antibiotics
during neurodevelopment of developing
offspring
and i quite like this outlook from this
nature summary
that also suggests that if you have
biomarkers of
the mother you might be able to
supplement back with
these different metabolites to try and
enhance the neural development
of their growing fetuses like there
already is
the supplementation of folic acids to
help with development of the neural tube
so i hope you've learned something from
this brief
paper overview and as always thanks for
listening